all right and we are live I love podcast
Lords of gaming.net I am Laura Cognito
here and who is this fine gentleman we
have in the realm of red fall today uh
I'm Murphy Smith the studio director of
Arcane in Austin and co-creative
director along with Ricardo bear of
redfall awesome awesome Lords here
getting a chance to get some gameplay
behind the scenes and first thing I want
to say off the bat the immersion in the
world just being able to explore this
world and see from a single player
perspective it was very unique what was
your mindset to kind of separate a
single player for the multiplayer
portion of the game yeah so we love solo
Play We love that immersion we love that
like exploring the world at your own
pace
so this is an open world game that
definitely works that way where it's
like all the other apartment games uh
you're now one of the first people in
the world to play it so you can testify
to that and we know that our values the
way we make games it plays very well
with the open world you can just like
come at it from any angle and all that
uh creative mechanics that you can
combine environmental storytelling
everywhere uh the truth is the co-op is
different like you can't go I mean you
can play alone or you can play with up
to four people and I'm here to tell you
if you're playing alone it very much
feels like an Arcane game as you can as
you can see now because you play it but
if you had four people it's something
different it plays different it's it's
like four people is more like a party
roving through the world you can't play
that slow pace anymore unless you have
really four people really working on
that somebody's gonna do something wild
crazy right someone's gonna break off
screen yeah
there's trade-offs so it's a different
game at that point uh but you play
through the same missions and stuff so
it's not like there's a co-op track or
whatever you either play redfall Solo or
if you play with one other person and
the two of you working together
that can still preserve the sort of
player slow pace and like the stealth
and inferring environmental storytelling
and stuff like that as soon as you had
that you know third person the fourth
person it speeds up it becomes something
different exactly and it's so key that I
feel that you guys have made that
distinction because as a person you know
I know saw if he's well our single
player selfish experience kind of person
so sometimes just being able to explore
the world and again the world that you
guys create with so much immersion and
just getting lost in it with the details
of what is important to a single player
person so I thought that was very cool
that studio made that decision to say
hey single player this is distinct in a
sense or from opposed to The Cooperative
experience yeah it really is an open
world it's like wide open and so you can
just wander and get lost in it I find
myself sometimes like getting up on the
roof and watching the sunset the fog
rolls in I zoom in and I I listen to
some overheard conversations I explore
an old house you know and I read the
notes in there and look at the graffiti
on the wall and blood stain on the floor
leading up to the the attic or whatever
you know it's it's not a dismal horror
game but it's spooky action right and so
there's like Halloween like horror
elements at least at that level it's
thrilling more than horrifying I guess
well I would say there was some
horrifying uh moments for me let's say
because once I was in that immersed in
the world and it was just exploring
houses almost going home the room
clearing scene what the vampires have
done in the world and then encountering
your vampires for the first time you
know it gave a feeling that they are
much quicker much faster than you and
you should you should be still prepared
and worried about them as well as the
cultists and everything around them so
um I've never mentioned before kind of
like what I noticed in the world like
this Blue Mist Red Mist kind of thing
and the red mix that would get kind of
hurt being in that could you explain
that a little bit Yeah there's like an
environmental damage system in the game
where like fire and electricity and UV
light are all relevant to
uh turning the tide about right like
blowing up a car setting off an
electrical box things like that there
are other hazards too leading a vampire
into a bunch of UV light or whatever and
then petrifying them and shattering them
that's all good but the vampires and the
cultists will drop this Red Mist you can
call it dead mist and you take damage in
it and it slows you down and sometimes
it chokes out like an entire Street for
100 yards so you have to find sort of
Empires take the vampires take humans
and convert them into different types of
familiars there's a watcher that has a
beam for the eyes there's a thing called
Sinead or this thing called blood bag
there's a blood bag if it gets petrified
it exudes death mist and so the whole
area will be flooded with red yes you
take your UV beam and you shine it on
the the blood bag and then shatter it
you can clearly the big blue Shimmer you
were talking about is that's a big
bubble it gets bigger and bigger and
everything within it is harder to fight
right so they're buffed so if you find
at the center of that there's a Ghostly
door and if you go into it you're in
psychic space you're in a nest if you go
to the center of that and find the heart
of the nest you can destroy it and clear
that blue bubble but it's funny to watch
people play Just earlier I was watching
somebody play this is a total out of The
Frying Pan Into the Fire moment because
they were in a fight Health was going
down vampire was coming at them they
blew up a car in the distance killed
some cultists backed up backed up backed
up and they backed up into the big boob
bubble turned around and there's a bunch
of harder to fight people coming at them
from the other side so uh yeah that's
you want to clear the nest when you can
to get rid of that yeah absolutely the
only thing I'll notice is the visual
nature of the combat which I didn't
expect in a sense of you know not only
do you would you shoot the vampires
they're in a down state yeah but they're
not finished right and you have to go
finish them talk about that mechanic
it's just the the combat aspect yeah
that was a thing we really wanted
Ricardo bushart for that as well that
like you can't just kill the vampires
with guns you can chew can kill monsters
with guns and lots of games but in our
game if you get them down you do enough
damage they go down there in a
vulnerable state they will regenerate
and come back from that similarly if you
UV them and they petrify and you leave
them alone for a while they will like
revive reanimate right so you have to
break off what you're doing while
they're down and go stake them yes yeah
or use fire electricity burn them up one
of your powers
Jacob can upgrade his Ravens so that it
can stake vampires as flying around
Layla can upgrade her umbrella so that
she unleashes it it dusts them as well
but fire is your friend in this game yes
absolutely the only thing I noticed is
the uniqueness as far as the weapons and
then almost as a person who plays that
game who plays like who the shoes I've
noticed almost category grades of
weapons things of that nature shotguns
close-up weapons semi-automatic weapons
even some very high powerful I was like
balloons and things like that what goes
into the thought process of that variety
of weapons and also like the distinction
from class
yeah we are comfortable putting the like
the weapons you see in other games we
use a fictional brand names because we
have no desire to give the weapons
manufacturer money but so we make up our
own fictional Brands uh but we have
shotguns assault rifles pistols machine
pistols all that kind of fun stuff then
we have a whole class of vampire Hunter
weapons and that the thought process
there is what's your game about that's
distinct our game is about New England
it's about psychic vampires created by
this scientific process where a company
called avam was looking to use the blood
of the young to extend the life of their
wealthy clients they accidentally
created vampires psychic based vampires
or science-based vampires not
Supernatural
but if you're going to lean into that
you won't vampire hunting guns so it's
it being an island a kind of a tourist
island with a lot of boating uh there's
a lot of flare guns lying around flare
gun becomes like a mini fireball you can
find a double barrel flare gun you know
and you can burn the vampires up with
that you also have a thing called a
state launcher they use this found ammo
like a snapped off pool cue or a mop
handle or something and you can stake
the vampires at a distance and the one
you alluded to is the UV beam yes it's
your personal portable way to to do UV
light and petrified the vampires and
then shatter them and then across all
the guns whether it's a shotgun or
pistol or the UV beam or whatever you
can find grades of weapons they yes you
level up through the game and you can
find higher and higher level weapons
eventually even your good guns you'll be
so high level compared to them that
you'll probably want to scrap them and
and get something higher level so you're
constantly churning through guns in this
game and eventually ideally you end up
with a very a set of very high quality
guns yeah the guns good the combat felt
great you know I definitely like what I
saw up there and then as far as just on
the narrative progressing you know one
thing kind of talked about was kind of
like you know what you do in the world
you know it's affected the other vampire
gods and other things see that so as I'm
assuming as you clear things out you
know whether it be the relationships
with the cultists or other vampires
things can immerse and happen actively
the world is that because yeah we have a
strong uh narrative in all of our games
both at the micro level where you're
looking at a room and you're like what
happened here this uh dead person in the
corner and a note over here and a red
Candle on the windowsill what does this
all mean let me read this note we have
that sort of micro level but we also
have the macro level where
whole series of story missions
you don't have to do all of them some of
them are optional some of them can be
done in different orders but there's a
story based campaign and then we have
sort of like a mid-level of narrative
where like and the game progresses as
you do all of that but like we have this
mid-level where it's a neighborhood
capture system where you go from
neighborhood to Neighborhood each
neighborhood has a safe house we can do
some some gameplay there to get the
generator on the UV lights come on start
at one of those safe houses yeah and
then you go into the safe house you can
take submissions there you can resupply
and once you've done the mission in the
safe house then you have an underboss
Mission so every neighborhood has an
underboss it's a named vampire with a
handcrafted set up to fight it and the
fog rolls in it's an elite vampire we
have a lease with uh Elites and specials
with traits that make them more powerful
as you play as you if you kill the
underboss you've secured that
neighborhood that neighborhood is safer
passing back and forth and after that
you can also use the safe house to fast
travel got you oh so that'll be a fast
travel system once you clear that out
there's historical markers that you can
find in the world and if you find them
flares go up from them and they're on
your map now and you can fast travel
over there and the safe house is awesome
that's awesome I love that aspect I know
what to ask like that obviously the team
to get close to the Finish Line you know
a lot of hard work you've been on
previous projects before what what are
some of the traits about redfall as you
want like new audience to know that hey
maybe they didn't know coming in and now
that you're getting close to the least
you've got to kind of let that out it's
a full open world but it's built on the
back of all the Arcane values
um you can hack turrets and pick locks
and get on the roof and watch the
sunrise uh you can fully explore the
players aren't tethered you can wander
the world I'm glad you said that because
I can get out to cut you boom one of my
concerns what's coming in I know they
was talking about you know online things
like that but one thing that I think is
a positive which suggests it is being
untethered in a Cooperative experience
hey solve is in one where every he's
going exploring I'm right there's not
this radius that keeps us like locked in
as other games like what was your
thought process to kind of open that up
from a technical Center
uh yeah well our we said we'd love this
and our core tech people were like
you're crazy we can't do that and we
said please and I said let's think about
it okay and so uh you know we thought
for a while we might have to tether uh
the four players together uh but the way
our system works it breaks the whole
world up into a bunch of 126 by 126
meter sectors and uh it handles
persistence with the player uh does
something in an area we mostly remember
those things
um it allows uh it is it does a very
good job of uh we don't let lights
overlap we do a lot a lot of things to
like keep the game running and perform
it and um
we just didn't find it necessary to
tether people so we do collect you up as
a group before you go into certain
Mission areas and such but generally if
you want to wander one into the street
and I'm going to go in the opposite
direction now the problem with that is
Let's Go the game is set for the
difficulty of two of us let's say the
three of us play the game is now scaled
out with a number of not bullet sponges
or not more enemies but rather the
number of Elites that you encounter you
find more specials and more Elites so
they're harder gotcha and so if I'm off
on my own I'll be fighting uh vampires
and cultists and Bellwether soldiers
that are uh set for the level of three
people fighting them and I'm on my own
so it's kind of a soft encouragement to
like come back together
right yeah exactly right no fair enough
I love that aspect game looks phenomenal
you know it plays great um I love the
atmosphere Everything feels good about
it and though yeah we're getting excited
we get excited
want to give PC game pass the whole bit
just so what's the relationship with
Michael and Microsoft as you get close
to the finish line and throughout the
process yeah this team has been through
so much along the way we started this
project before coven uh we've had you
know a pandemic everybody went work from
home we had the great resignation uh and
Austin we had multiple ice storms that
shut the electrical grid down for weeks
at a time we had to boil our water for a
while the country had an Insurrection we
had important social movements happening
across the country right this we had
murder Hornets the Air Force was talking
about aliens at one point we had so many
things happen in the last few years that
I think would have tanked a lot of
development teams and Arcane we didn't
work people too hard we gave everybody
Fridays off during the worst part of the
pandemic we the company was kind enough
to extend the date so that we could just
not have to crunch ourselves to death
um and we just kept putting the love
into it now one of the things that
happened on
the reason I was rattling all that stuff
off his company got bought my Microsoft
and uh that's a big sea change as well
for us but you know what uh so far it's
been awesome uh you know we're on Game
Pass PC and Xbox in some sense that
allows us to focus on fewer platforms so
we can dedicate ourselves but also the
number of people that are going to be
looking at this game because of Game
Pass is bigger I think than anything
Arcane has seen before I don't remember
the number of subscribers that were on
game passes going up all the time but
that's a lot of people who are going to
be like oh I have Game Pass look the new
Arcane games out let me play that and so
uh it's really an exciting idea
and then it's also because the game is
um there's no MTX in the game no store
but it's online and so we can keep
updating it if we see in a given period
that everybody's dying from falling we
can adjust falling damage or ladder code
or whatever to try to you know reduce
those deaths
so it's a it's a really exciting model
to be working in I know it's awesome
it's good to see like I said you guys
persevered through all those obstacles
obviously you get Acquired and then you
get closer to the Finish Line to see
people all come together game
development is hard it's not easy and
it's really cool to see that you
mentioned that last thing I wanted to
ask in reference to the characters a lot
of flavor a lot of Personality Layla
who's doing a little absorb the the
bullets coming at me shoot them back and
super with her boyfriend comes out and
he's vampire fighting with me kind of
thing you know you got three other
characters currently right now
um just briefly the distinctions and
maybe your favorite characters you know
between all four that occur uh yeah I
mean you mentioned a few things in there
I do think this is our best feeling
shooter uh like we always do direct
combat or stealth environmental
storytelling a little RPG features a
little shooter features uh and our guns
feel okay normally I think this is the
first time I think our guns feel great I
love our guns and it does feel very
visceral the sake of Empire and all that
um but in terms of the characters we
have four at launch uh Defender Crosley
is a guy from the UK he's kind of a
Cryptid Hunter and a streamer he's
always the YouTuber he's always been a
True Believer in Yeti and Sasquatch or
not he doesn't believe it's Sasquatch
actually I think that's the one he calls
ridiculous but he believes in ghosts and
vampires and things so uh this is an
exciting moment for him uh Layla was a
medical student on the island who
volunteered for some uh blood trials
with Avon and ended up with telekinetic
Powers uh Remy De la Rosa is uh the
combat engineer with a little miniature
bot called reborn she goes she's a
search and rescue uh operator she goes
into flood zones and fire zones and War
zones and pulls people out of the
wreckage rebound is a lot of fun to play
with he'll fight your enemies
she Buffs the team with her rally power
she got a C4 block as well
um and last but not least is Jacob who
was he's a sniper from Bellwether yeah
and they're they're kind of the bad guys
but Jacob got separated from them and
joined the team and so he's probably the
most questionable up front but one other
thing I'll say about the characters and
we haven't talked too much about this is
if you play alone you play alone right
you don't have the other Squad with with
you you're totally solo yeah and let's
say you're playing with the vendor and
you're moving through the world he will
comment on things if you're playing
Layla and you go past the yogurt shop
she'll say like oh my God I got yogurt
here so many times my freshman year uh
if you're playing with another character
they will have a corresponding line so
if you're playing with Jacob and Layla
she might say that and he might say when
I was where I was growing up we didn't
have yogurt we just had ice cream you
know so they'll go back and forth and at
first they're almost like strangers the
longer they play together there's this
thing called the trust system okay where
their lines get more and more intimate
more like you say my life I've saved
your life they become friends and
there's a mechanical buff called the
trust buff builds up over time when you
play with them as well so if you play
consistently repeatedly with a set of
characters they build up trust between
them and their lines get more intimate
so that's like a little narrative
feature that we like
so I don't have a favorite character
I've played all of them
and they're all fun in different ways
right they all respond in different ways
yeah it just depends
you ain't thinking about monkey's kids
that's okay
look we have got a chance to play Lord's
got a chance to play redfall again May
2nd and a second it comes out and they
second we're getting close to Finish
Line the game feels absolutely awesome
love the environment love the skill
trees as well just being a deep dive and
configure the way I wanted to configure
to empower certain abilities the exact
nature Gunplay feels great we're getting
excited for any final things you want to
say to the realm of what we close out
here oh God but there's so much to make
this game we're so proud of it we hope
you love it as much
uh and along the way we've tried to
communicate what it is and they always
say like talking about music is like
dancing about architecture right it's
very hard to convey what a game is so
you put your hands on it right and so
that's why it's so gratifying that
people have not played it uh because
they will all walk away from this press
tour first people in the world that
really played the game besides the team
they walk away saying wow this really is
open world this really does feel like an
atmospheric single player Arcane
experience
salute
[Music]